pensemos un poco lo que fue la mañana de
hoy para cada uno de nosotros
probablemente a todos les sonó el
celular que estaba conectado
al enchufe lo dejaron cargando de la
noche fueron la cocina pusieron agua en
ya sea en la tetera o en un calefactor
pan en el tostador jamón o queso el
refrigerador se iría para acá o
manejando o en metro o en bicicleta
cada una de esas actividades uno lo
piensa en detalle tiene un componente
profundo de energía imbuido
y eso no debería llamarnos la atención
porque desde la revolución industrial a
la fecha el consumo energético de cada
una de nuestras actividades diarias en
lo profesional y en lo personal ha sido
creciente constante
y todavía va a seguir siéndolo si uno
mira el poco el consumo per cápita de
cada uno de los chilenos representa casi
un tercio de lo que consumen países como
suecia y un cuarto de lo que de lo que
consumen per cápita países como noruega
y si uno piensa en china y en india no
está concentrado más de un tercio de la
población de nuestro planeta
todavía queda muchísimo consumo de
energía por crecer de nivel a nivel per
cápita pero esto ha tenido una
consecuencia
ha tenido consecuencias profundas en
nuestra atmósfera y los efectos de
cambio climático y la razón principal de
esto tiene que ver con que la generación
eléctrica y el consumo energético
principalmente lo hemos obtenido de la
quema de combustibles fósiles ya sea el
petróleo el carbón y el gas natural y
sus derivados
y las consecuencias de estas masivas
emisiones de gases invernadero en
nuestro país al menos y probablemente en
buena parte del mundo han sido super
latente las constantes sequías en la
zona centro y sur las torrenciales
lluvias en la zona norte donde
históricamente
ahí hay más bien un clima un clima seco
entonces tenemos ya dos paradigmas
por un lado quemamos para consumir
energía y sabemos que vamos a conseguir
consumir mucha más energía de la que
estamos consumiendo hoy día y tenemos un
desafío cambio climático y responder qué
planeta le vamos a dar a las futuras
generaciones este paradigma se resuelve
básicamente pasando una de una matriz
que está
imbuida
la quema combustibles fósiles hace una
matriz energética limpia y la buena
noticia para chile y estos son
resultados oficiales la última
licitación de distribuidoras es que la
energía solar en chile con los niveles
de radiación que tenemos es un tercio
más barata que la energía producida con
carbón
pero dado eso si uno mira los
las estadísticas de producción de
energía del año 2016 sigue siendo dos
tercios de nuestra matriz proveniente de
combustibles fósiles entonces qué es lo
que está pasando ahí porque si una
energía más barata si es más limpia
seguimos generando energía a través de
combustibles fósiles y la razón
principal tiene que ver con la curva de
demanda en chile la demanda de energía
es prácticamente plana durante el día y
durante la noche y la energía solar y
también el viento solamente producen
cuando el recurso está disponible o sea
las horas de luz o cuando sobra el
viento y eso no necesariamente es
compatible con una demanda que es
continua durante el día y durante la
noche entonces la clave para resolver
este esta coyuntura tiene que ver como
almacenamos energía de manera
tremendamente eficiente para llenar los
espacios donde el recurso no está
disponible si la energía solar ocupamos
esa energía barata y limpia para
almacenarla y entregarla en la noche y
en la madrugada
y nuevamente el norte de chile ofrece
una solución tremendamente creativa para
resolver esta problemática y lo ofrece a
través de la geografía donde finalmente
lo que tenemos son dos cuerpos de agua
los cuales están unidos entre sí a
través de túneles a diferentes alturas
entonces cuando tenemos acceso de
energía lo que hacemos ocupamos exceso
para subir agua de un reservorio
inferior a uno superior y cuando tenemos
déficit de energía esa agua que está
arriba es energía potencial que está
disponible para ser generada a través de
un sistema hidráulico convencional como
los que existen en la cordillera de la
zona centro-sur de nuestro país si uno
corta un perfil del norte básicamente es
lo que ve tenemos el mar que es infinito
tenemos una cordillera que nos da la
altura y sobre esta cordillera un
farallón
que nos permite almacenar agua de manera
tremendamente eficiente porque no hay
que hacer represas y estos dos cuerpos
de agua en altura están muy cerca uno
del otro con esto la gran ventaja que
tenemos con chile es que no solamente
podemos producir la energía solar más
barata del mundo sino que además podemos
almacenarla de manera tremendamente
eficiente y así poder ofrecer energía
limpia chilena continua y barata durante
las 24 horas del día
cuando aprendamos una luz
o se despiertan en la mañana yo creo que
el futuro de chile es apunta a que esa
energía que estemos ocupando sea 100%
renovable muchas gracias
[Aplausos]